now to our coverage of the coronavirus  there are several  vaccine clinics being held around the  valley next week in addition to  this week as well you're looking there  at the listing for the mexican consulate  hosting one on tuesday from nine in the  morning until one  desert pines high is also having one  from 2 30 to 6 in the afternoon  now this is in addition to the major  vaccine sites that are  in existence all across southern nevada  we have a full list available for you at  8newsnow.com  later this afternoon governor steve  sisselak will reveal nevada's new  vaccine  encouragement plan vax nevada days are  part of a program to get more of us  vaccinated against the coronavirus  the solution a reward to get the shots  basically  a lottery we're going to carry the  coverage of this live on 8 news now at 4  o'clock